welcome to the live q a
i'm aj hammerly from the developer
relations team
in today's q a we'll be focusing on
questions related to urza's keynote
hidden forces what's next in enterprise
i.t
if you haven't had a chance to watch it
yet that's fine viewers will give us a
60 second recap shortly and then you can
watch the whole thing later
and if you have a burning question that
you really want me to ask ours
there's still time you need to make sure
you're registered and logged in
on the next on-air website and then
click on the open q a button which is
directly below this video
and now coming to us live from zurich
i'd like to introduce
urs holtzly google's svp of technical
infrastructure hi aja
hi everyone uh yes i'm morris hudsley
and i'm
responsible for the technical
infrastructure at google that's
all away from the hardware and the data
centers and the networks
up to the software and the cloud
platform
itself and in case you missed it this
morning uh in my keynote i talked about
uh two key things for cloud and
for the enterprise uh first that
enterprise innovation can catch up
to the rate of consumer innovation but
only
if the enterprise adopts a always
up-to-date software stack that works
across
any cloud and on-premise course and edge
and second that anthos is
exactly this stack and that it will play
a role similar to what linux played
uh 20 years or so again uh as
a goal um so anthos is
you know as safe and as clear a choice
as
back then was choosing linux because
it runs everywhere it's based on
open source and kubernetes uh because
it's based on kubernetes everything will
run
on top of that and so that makes anthos
a safe choice for the next decade or two
because when you choose it
you don't really give up any other
choices
just like when you choose linux so that
in a nutshell
was what i talked about this morning and
i'm looking forward
to answering your questions either on
that or pretty much anything else so
with that uh back to you asha
thanks for the recap i'm sure that a lot
of people haven't had a chance to watch
the whole video yet
and so i'm i'm interested and i'll make
sure that
people i know watch it later so first
question this one's from our developer
community
and the question is what can managers
and leaders do to help their teams adopt
modern development workflows and tools i
know that this is a question we get a
lot
as advocates when we're out in the field
people want to know
where do i start what can i do how do i
make this smooth for my team
a great question and actually a
much easier asked than answered so
there's
no magic bullet in the end i think the
key
i would say is to
um try to learn from someone else and in
a way that's what we're trying to do
with anthos so you can look at anthos
as a technology stack but it's just as
much
a set of practices that have proven to
work well over time and when so when you
use
anthos you're really introduced to those
techniques be that
about the development itself or how you
push uh
do gradual pushes or actually how you
operate or how you secure
so i think the key thing is that um
you want to pick something where
actually the workflow itself
uh is is opinionated someone's actually
thought about it
and where you buy not just a piece of
technology or you don't just
use a number of tools but you really use
it together
in in sort of an end-to-end way and you
try to learn from the best there's a ton
of content on
uh youtube and so on and there's a ton
of content
on our uh developer uh websites
and that's actually what uh aja and and
and her team are great
uh for oh i'm glad you think so so
you're saying that anthos is both
technology and
best practices that have been tried and
true by people who've done this a lot
like google but others and one of those
best practices that i've heard a lot
about
is multi-cloud it's one of the main
things that people are excited about
that i talked to with anthos although
there's lots of cool things in anthos
can you talk a bit about multi-cloud
like what are some of the trade-offs or
versus
benefits of going with a multi-cloud
strategy versus a single cloud strategy
i know this is something a lot of bigger
companies are thinking about right now
yep yep yeah i think actually um
um that is a much easier question
because the whole
premise like the trade-off usually comes
in the
in two forms you know one it says well
at the upside of multi-cloud obviously
is that
you know if you pick something are you
really gonna sure be
be sure that for the next 20 years this
is the right vendor
uh to pick and so you want to have
options and also
you know you want to use the best of of
any world right
and and and move at your own pace you
know leave some things on premise
because right now you don't want to deal
with it you know move them at your own
time
but then the downside or the portrait
downside is that well
if you use let's say if you use three
clouds
you actually need to train your team
three times and you do security in three
different ways
and you do all kinds of things three
different ways plus if you want to be
common between them you're really
dumbing down
what your cloud is and you're sort of
giving up
most of the advantage of cloud now
fortunately
that is actually false and and anthony's
actually shows
why because the the beauty of anthos
is that it doesn't try
to do too much it standardizes the
things that should not be different the
things that aren't necessarily
um special um let's say how do you
how do you actually release a binary how
do you
configure something how do you define a
load balancer
how do you distribute certificates to
your services these are all things you
have to do every day
and they should not be different between
the clouds
and so anthon says learn it once without
false and then you can pick
your cloud or multiple clouds or stay on
premise
and you don't have to learn that task
again so for all the tasks and
and practices and workflows that anfos
covers
you really have just one team one time
where you have to learn it
and then you can still take the
advantage of of of the uniqueness
of each environment without having to
relearn you know all the basics again so
fortunately i think
this is a a false trade-off and i think
you really want to pick a platform that
does not lock you in
for the next 20 years into one way
of doing things right so in my view
that's that's an easy answer pure win
you know go with multi-cloud or be ready
for multi-cloud and have the option
because who knows what's going to happen
in the next 10 20 years
yeah so it sounds like and this was my
understanding that multi-cloud has a lot
of advantages
flexibility being able to do things on
the right timeline for your team
being able to use specific cloud
specific features that you need
but anthos is kind of the secret sauce
here and that it takes away all a lot of
the disadvantages about having to learn
multiple clouds about having have a team
trained on multiple clouds
and that's awesome i i know that i've
had to make a decision about on-prem or
cloud or both
and both was always scary just because
of the sheer information overload that
we had to keep track of and i'm glad
anthos exists now
didn't have it back then so now we've
got a question from twitter
according to you what are the missing
pieces of cloud today
um uh i'd say lots and actually let me
put it in a slightly different way i
think
if we put ourselves you know in our mind
into 2025 and we look back
on 2020 and the cloud of 2020
um i think we'll be embarrassed that we
liked it
and that we thought it was good right
because it will seem
incredibly primitive uh because even
though cloud is
you know 10 years old um it actually
still
is in its early stages so i often
compare it to kind of mobile phones
after their first 10 15 years
it was sort of nokia and blackberry
right it wasn't android
and ios and so the android and ios of
cloud is still coming and one of the
things that really made
that explosion of functionality in the
mobile space that made you really
rethink what you you expect of a mobile
phone that made you
look back on your on your feature phone
and kind of be
surprised that you ever liked it right
was the fact that there
were software platforms that you know a
set of apis that were auto update and
that allowed you to roll out
your service to anyone on that platform
and not have a ton of friction from you
know version matrix
and sort of anything and so that's one
of the things that i think really today
is missing
in a cloud if you're on a single cloud
then things
are fine in a sense they're consistent
but
you know beware if you ever see the need
to either remain on-premise or use
another cloud because it has an awesome
service because you're just
completely starting from scratch and i
think five years from now you'll just
say wow i cannot believe that this was
missing
you know back then it's kind of like
saying what there were phones without an
app store on it that is really
hard to believe like you mean a phone
that was there like to make calls
that's really all it did like it's hard
for us to think about today so i think i
predict that in 2025
um we'll really be in that point where
we where we kind of are embarrassed
about the cloud of 2020
because from the developers perspective
from the security perspective
from the operations perspective and
really from the portability perspective
you know today's cloud and actually
today's cloud
world really isn't a great world and and
and we want to change that
awesome and the phone analogy is super
helpful i know that i explained to my
nieces a couple months ago that my first
blackberry only had the game snake and
they were horrified
horrified that i didn't have an app
store to use so i'm curious what that's
going to look like it's going to be
amazing for the cloud world to have that
big of a transformation
and so quickly so let's take another
question from the dory
actually this question's from a
developer community and this one's uh
close to my heart as a manager
how do you effectively manage high
performing technical teams my team is
awesome and any tips you can give for
the managers in the audience about how
we can do better would be great
um wow okay that's a complicated
question again so
there's no simple answer i think the one
thing i would
always mention first that people really
underappreciate
is hiring because if you
hire the right people then a
it's going to make a bigger difference
than anything else you do
and b management actually becomes
much easier because you have great
people
who are doing a great job and they need
your support but they don't really need
your sort of corrective action all the
time and let me just
double down on the importance of hiring
um
like if you think about it suppose that
you're at your company
and suppose you spend a full 10 of your
time for an entire year
right so 10 every single week you
spend on hiring right you interview
people
you're trying to recruit people whatever
right and suppose for
all that effort you find just one person
a
single person you know in that year who
is as good as you are right i would
argue that with that 10 of your time
you have doubled your productivity right
to the company
and there's nothing else you can do in
10 of your time
that doubles your impact right there's
really nothing else like you cannot work
harder you can't you know make better
tools
like it just does not give you a factor
of 10. so hiring really i think is the
key to management
and i think if you pay attention to that
if you do that well then the rest
follows
much more easily awesome
that's a really insightful answer and
i'll have to think a bit more about that
so let's take a let's take a more nerdy
question from the dory um operational
frictions
oftentimes leads to learning
opportunities eliminating friction
equals eliminating opportunities for
people to learn i think what this
question is saying is that when stuff
goes wrong
and your pager goes off it is just
another learning opportunity
is that always good uh that
is right so i mean there's a good
observation that i'd separated in in two
ways right one
is any average company
um there is so much productive learning
like
learning that you want to do because you
get
advantages from it and it's sort of pure
upside right you you learn about
containers about ci cd
or you know whatever in the average
company there's so much in need of that
that you really want to focus
on that kind of learning versus learning
from your mistakes
right so to speak or from outages now
the second part is that actually it is
very important
to learn from your outages or to learn
from your mistakes
so in case of outages you know
postmortems and especially blameless
postmortems
like focusing on what went wrong and how
do we prevent that from happening not
like who made a mistake
right so blameless postmortems and
learning from mistakes
again like maybe a postmortem for
something in your project or a technical
decision
that's really when the learning happens
so i agree with you that
that like the best way to summarize that
is you know let no crisis go to waste
right a crisis is a huge opportunity to
actually change how you're doing things
and avoid the next crisis so i'm i'm
definitely a big fan
but i think if that becomes the dominant
form of your learning then
you know you're in a you're in a
problematic spot
yeah no you don't you don't want
everything to be on fire all the time
and i'm really glad you mentioned
blameless post-mortems more than
anything i've learned in my five years
at google learning about the blameless
post-mortem culture
and how you can learn as a team and do
better as a team has done
wonders not only for my work life but
also for my personal life and dealing
with
stuff that goes sideways at home
especially especially right now
so yeah that's great so now a question
from twitter
um who are your inspirations when it
comes to tech
who do you look up to uh
boy i don't want to name my favorite uh
my favorite children so to speak
but i think what i admire and what
inspires me
is when there are things
that in retrospect seem obvious
but nobody thought of them for 10 years
right so if someone finds something that
that you know five even even two years
from now
right if someone hears about it is like
yeah that seems pretty obvious
that it's done this way but it took 10
years 20 years
to find that that to me is is
is as i you know the most the most
amazing thing
and and the thing i admire most in
people so it's really
often the the simplicity that actually
makes something
awesome uh versus uh
you know something incredibly
complicated that you know sometimes is
unavoidable but really what i admire
are are are things that seem obvious
but until they became obvious they
weren't obvious
that makes sense and it's definitely
been my experience
here i got some advice early on in my
career that you should always be
cautious of the person who asks
asks the seemingly dumb question because
they've likely seen
they've likely seen how simpler your
solution could be so that's great
so our next question is uh from i
believe the dory
and it is kind of long so i'm going to
read it but then i'm going to try to
summarize it a bit
so the question says i'm worried that
the cloud and run k native push for
scale to zero is leaving customers with
cascading long late startup latency
issues as they move to microservices
which get paged or swapped out while not
in use uh can you endorse a scale to one
alternative please to have support
always having an instance ready to
support always having instance ready so
this actually seems
slightly like a feature request less
than a question but it does bring
up an interesting question about how do
you prioritize
the advantages of something like scale
to zero and adopting a microservices
architecture
over the fact that there are some
downsides uh scale to zero has
startup latency issues like how would
you address that if you were trying to
work on it work with the team that was
migrating to
microservices architecture on say kk
native yep
great question um so first of all not my
job to endorse something or not
you know like i i i uh you know i'm not
a sports star that gets paid
for product placement so to speak um so
i would actually
uh uh answer it slightly differently
and you know it's not the job of uh
you know the provider to pick it's
really the job of
of each of the teams to pick and you
know i always say
engineering is the art of the compromise
because
if there was a dominant you know best
answer then you know would be pretty
boring and pretty easy because like
everyone does that
and end the story right and so so it's
really about trade-offs
and the trade-offs differ you know by
industry by customer
by team even right and so in this
particular case
the nice thing about scale to zero is
zero cost
when you don't use it and so for some
things that's a really great solution
like suppose you have an internal app
and it gives you the w-2 that
um you know you download for those of
you international w-2 is your tax form
for you know your end-of-year tax form
well you know
probably 360 days of the year nobody
uses that app
and you don't want to pay for it so
scale to zero is great and if the first
person
has to wait you know a second or two to
download their tax
uh return that's fine because you know
once tax season is there
the application is probably hot right on
the other hand as you say
that actually if you have an a different
app that maybe is
you know idle for a little while but
then is being used again
and then idle for a while and used again
you kind of don't want to introduce
you know multi-second startup latency
for the poor person who's the next uh
person to
to to use your app so so to me that's a
trade-off i think it's a good feature
request
you can actually easily implement that
yourself by
just having a little actually you should
probably do end-to-end monitoring of
your key workflows and so
if you did that frequently enough you
will keep
your functions warm and and your startup
latency is low but to me
again it really comes down to
engineering and
figuring out what is the business value
right what problem are we solving and
what are the options that we have
and among these which one is the least
worst right you know sometimes called
the best
right usually the best isn't actually
flawless
right everything has has some problems
so that that i think is a great place
uh uh to to to to to end
and and really say you know i agree with
you should be actually a simple
configuration option
like never going down to zero i value
latency over
totally minimal cost i don't think we
have that in k native but
you know if you know how to file a
feature request i think it's a good one
actually yeah so
it seems like the answer is like the
answer to almost every technical
question
is it depends it depends on your use
case and it depends on
you know what the right choice for your
engineering team is which might have to
do with the people you have and the time
they have in the skills they have so
that's amazing and i know that there's
i don't know that we don't have it i i
should know the answer to this and i
don't and i'm
slightly embarrassed about that uh so
next question from twitter
actually no this next question is from
the dory uh oh this is a good one
um what are some of your favorite failed
google infrastructure projects there
were such cool ideas that they had to be
tried
irrespective of the outcome
well uh first of all if you knew the
outcome you wouldn't have tried it
probably even if it wasn't cool right
so so i mean you know feelings happen
because you you don't quite predict
what's going to happen i think
uh on an infrastructure side one of the
things i would want to mention actually
goes back
15 years ago so 15 years ago we got
into uh building our own data centers
because we were sort of running out of
rented data centers and we could see the
time that the rents would really go up
because up until about that point
you know for those of you who were there
the internet bubble burst in 2000
and there was just both loads of data
center space that was empty
and was cheap to rent and so as we were
growing we were really growing
into a lot of empty space that went
through bankruptcies and
and therefore was really cheap but so as
we were
seeing that coming to an end we we
thought about like well what do we do to
make
our own data centers and obviously they
got to be cheap
and not just cheap to build but also
cheap to operate and one of the things
we noticed was that
you know almost half of our data center
bill was
energy you know power and what was
actually really offensive
is that a significant fraction of that
again
about half of that was completely wasted
like it wasn't
actually energy to power your cpu
and your memory it just went elsewhere
the building cooling
your power supply like all kinds of
places that you didn't really care about
right and so we started to build more
efficient data centers and our first
approach
was uh what's called the containerized
data center
and so basically the idea was instead of
building really a building and trying to
cool the building why don't you just
cool the servers and by the way put
those servers into literally a shipping
container
and then inside that shipping container
it's very easy to control the airflow
and then you have sort of a modular unit
where you can deploy
let's say space for a thousand servers
at a time and you just put this in a
warehouse and you can go to youtube
uh look for uh container data center
google something like that we we have
some videos
way back from 2005 and it turned out to
be
a great idea in some expect in some
aspects like it was actually
um um uh very efficient
and it was pretty cheap but it turned
out those containers were actually sort
of unwieldy you needed a large buildings
to kind of maneuver them
in and out and the crane and all kinds
of things and
and then also it would really constrain
your space right that the shipping
container is a fixed form factor
you have to kind of cram in your servers
and they were not really
you know deep enough etc and so really
that was
you know a a big failure in some extent
like we we did it once and never again
but at the same time it was really one
of these classic opportunities where
it was fairly fast to fail and we
learned a time and we actually used a
lot of those principles
in our next data center which we
contained we actually called container
less
uh or the non-tainer like the
non-container
where we we could preserve a lot of the
cooling
uh efficiency and and the cheapness but
basically
you know put all of that into the row of
the server versus
you know an entire enclosure right and
so today even today
what what you see sort of in each server
ray evro is
actually looks pretty low tech if you go
look up some pictures or some videos
it's just kind of metal and
the metal is really sort of a mini
container for for a server that's in
each slot
but we don't have the container around
so that that is probably one of my
favorite failures because it definitely
was a failure like like that was not in
the end a
great idea but it led to actually rapid
innovation in the data center space and
actually was a
step that that
you know though you partially regret it
um was a failure that really paid off
yeah i remember i remember reading a lot
about google's containerized data
centers and
uh those were those were cool and i'm
glad that
lots of cool technology came out of it
too and we do approach it they were
actually hot
they were actually hot 27 degrees they
were hot yes of course
and google's all about containers so
last question
um what will the next game changer
within cloud b is it going to be quantum
computing
um probably
not the next one because quantum
computing is one of these things that
you know when it works it will be
awesome but at the same time there's
some
really you know pretty big problems left
and though
we're kind of making progress um it's
always
kind of five years plus out right and
when someone tells you it's five years
out
they really kind of mean i'm not sure
how long it will take
right so i hope that there's innovation
in cloud before
um i do think that uh
one of the game changers really is to
change
cloud away from thinking about it as
three different clouds and you have to
choose
one of the three i think that really is
going to be outdated very soon
and it's going to kind of feel like for
those of you who were around
in 1995 in 1995
it was sort of servers were new you know
away from mini computers and and
mainframes
uh pcs were new x86 you know unix was
new
uh you know every like java was new like
the enterprise really kind of needed to
change how it did computing
back then everyone sort of obsessed
about should i pick
deck or sun or compact like which vendor
do i pick
which hardware vendor but it was not
just a hardware vendor because if you
pick
one hardware render you got a different
os and you got a different compiler and
you got a different databases and like
you picked the whole thing
everything was different right and
that's kind of the mode that we're in
today with cloud if you
if you pick one cloud then like the way
you start the container or the way you
start a vm is different
from somewhere else but that actually
kind of doesn't make sense
it's just starting a container and in
the end sort of everyone does the same
thing so why isn't it the same
so in the server space back in in 95
it took about 10 years for that to play
out and 10 years later people realized
that
it's not about picking the server vendor
that's important for hardware reasons
but it's not a choice that you have to
stick with
for the next 20 years the choice that
matters is
back in 2005 was linux versus windows
server
right like if you picked one of them
that stayed with you
for a decade or two and in this
particular case if you picked linux
and if you picked open source you really
picked a growing ecosystem
around it and you could pick anything
below and pretty much
anything above and so that's what we're
really trying to do
to the cloud space without those to say
you know antos is kind of like minix
it's not the same because it's managed
so you do get open source but you don't
have to worry about the updates and
security patches etc
but it actually has the same sort of
horizontal property
where now you don't really care about
what's below you may still
care about it for performance or cost
reasons but it's not a stack
that's below it's kind of more like
hosting and then above
it's pretty much anything so any service
you want to
consume any any any any any development
practice you want to use
you can do that and that's independent
of the environment so that to me really
actually is
a game changer because it moves the
whole thinking away
from sort of the aol model like pic pico
l and
aol and everything is the aol way to the
internet model where you pick
open standards and then you can mix and
match
and really adopt the things that work
best for you and do something you know
like if you picked linux 20 years ago
it's still with you and it's still a
great choice because all the other
things around it you could show it
you could you could change your your
your opinion your choice
and so linux didn't constrain you in
that way and that's really i think what
the big
revolution in cloud will be that that
and those uh together with kubernetes
gives you that same portability and that
same
learn it once and then just you know do
it for the next 10 years
that really changes how people look at
cloud
that makes a lot of sense and it totally
makes sense that
moving toward open standards that work
anywhere is going to give people the
flexibility to do what's right for them
which is
awesome so i want to thank you so much
for chatting with us today and sharing
your thoughts and insights and i want to
thank
our audience for joining us virtually
and submitting some really insightful
thoughtful questions uh this q a
isn't the only thing we have going on
this week at next on air though there's
lots going on and i want to encourage
all of you to check out some of the
other things
so if you want to dig in and learn more
we have a couple different options
available
first of all you can book a one-on-one
session with a googler chat or video
chat
for 15 minutes talk more about the
products or specific problems you have
or find out more about you know what
learning content is right for you
to do that you can book a session at the
url
on your screen right now i also want to
do a shout out for my team we're hosting
a live developer talk session this
friday
two folks i work with dave and ian are
going to be hosting that
and you want to learn more about that
the url is the second one
on your screen talks by devrel
and i know a lot of folks i've
definitely like this and i know a lot of
our developer audience just wants to dig
in and get their hands dirty they don't
they don't want to hear about it they
don't want to read about they just want
to try it and if that's you
it doesn't have to be all of you but
there's probably a few of you in the
audience
i can recommend our learning hub go to
the next learning hub and go do a code
lab do some tutorials
just get your hands dirty try it see if
it's gonna work for you that's the
fastest way often to
fail fast and learn if something is the
right match for the problems you
currently have
and check out the rest of our content as
part of next on air we've done
a lot of work to create super cool talks
demos and other ways that you can learn
about what's happening what's new
and what models are working for people
who use google cloud
i've been really proud of the work
that's happened in the talks that have
been created
so finally close out i want to thank i
thought i want to thank guruz again and
i want to thank all of you for showing
up this was fantastic and i learned a
lot
thank you to aja and thanks everyone for
joining us
[Music]
you